now how a chair or the lack of one has
dashed hopes for smoother relations
between the eu
and turkey two of the european union's
top leaders
ozola fonda line and sean michel visited
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
in ankara on wednesday
but as the three gathered for talks
there were only two
chairs present what happened next has
turned into a diplomatic scandal
it was a meeting that set hopes for
re-engagement between the eu and turkey
but mending ties got off to a rocky
start
one of the eu's most powerful female
executives was left without somewhere to
sit
instead of being placed in equal rank
according to diplomatic protocol
ursula von deland the european
commission president was placed on a
sofa
while the men took center stage
it draws stark comparison to previous
years where eu and turkish leaders were
seated
in equal standing whether the optics
were intentional or not
it may have added further strain to the
relationship but the spokesman for the
european commissioner says she wanted to
focus on the issues at hand
she chose to prioritize substance over
questions of
form or protocol and that's certainly
what european citizens would have
expected of her
it is not my job to judge what was
behind the fact that we offered her one
type of seat
over another a key focal point for the
eu
was for turkey to improve its human
rights record
ankara recently withdrew from a treaty
that protects women against
violence and discrimination the country
has seen nationwide protests
against femicide where domestic violence
and murders of women are on the rise
and the diplomatic faux pas has sparked
outrage online
[Music]
some called out the political strains
between the eu and turkey
others say it reflects how women are
treated in the country
and took aim at the european council
president for not playing his part in
standing beside the european commission
president
turkish officials are pointing blame at
the eu
the requests of the eu are met and the
proper protocols applied in the scope of
this high-level meeting that took place
in our presidency the seating
arrangements were made
in line with the eu's suggestion
for now it may be a long road ahead to
establish better ties
between the two sides
you